whatever that dream in your head is that
it's actually probably even small
compared to what you're capable of and
that it's possible and that people with
less intelligence and less resources
than you Your Heroes a lot of them
started with less than what you have
right now a lot of your Heroes didn't
have anybody and they figured it out and
they can you can too and it requires a
different way of thinking it requires a
different way of acting it requires you
maybe saying no to some people and then
saying yes to new people and new
opportunities in your life but your
dream is possible and you just have to
wake up every day and take one more step
towards making momentum happen towards
it because I think for a lot of people
the biggest thing they're missing is
just momentum